now I'm not going to add any more points
but we are gonna add a one more line
gonna be the last one okay
I'm a triangle kid I don't know a lot of
points in here I want to do an a/b
that's the hypotenuse here okay now last
me point third and last lucky lost okay
where is it going to be I estimate it'll
be a bad yeah okay what shall I call it
and Capo an and because the new point of
a and B I'm gonna call it baby
okay now to work out its coordinates
this is interesting because we've
actually done all the work already
we actually have can you see why we
can't define as you want to work out
distances but we don't need to worry
about the distance yes okay very good
very good
let's stop let's show that actually I'll
say again in case they don't catch it um
this new point the last one right it's
lined up it's in line with the other two
midpoints we just worked out right so
maybe you want to do this as well put a
dotted line across like so thank you see
that and one more dotted line like this
okay so that means its x-coordinate now
where are we gonna get its x-coordinate
from
the middle of a yeah very good the
escort of this will be the same as the
x-coordinate obvious because there are
the same vertical line right it's
directly above so it'll be four right
what about the y-coordinate it'll be
three the same as this guy because
everything on this horizontal line will
have that same y-coordinate so it's four
three okay so what are we done we worked
out these kinds of midpoints right and
they gave us the video point on this
gave us the x and y-coordinates okay but
we don't wanna have to draw a diagram
like this and go through all these
different points every single time we
want to boil it down to something nice
and simple something like one of these a
formula right so this is our last one by
the way midpoint it's going to be equal
to no let's have a think about this
right a distance is just a telemarketer
linked by it's just a number like five
units or 23 units or something like that
see you in a with a number Grady it's
also ANOVA so when you stick in all of
these X's and Y's you just get a number
out but a midpoint a big point has
coordinates right so therefore we should
have coordinates in here some kind of
coordinates right so I just want to work
out what they are now see these things
here right this is how we worked out the
midpoint so here and here that's how we
did those values okay so I'm gonna bring
that approach over here to the formula
okay this first one is the first one you
worked out was their average or the
midpoint of the X's right for here so
one of these two numbers again 71 it's
the significance of those very good yes
points of a and P also at the x
coordinates of a and B right so
therefore I want to say we'll take those
x coordinates right just like all these
previous times we'll just call them x1
and x2 those are the x coordinates you
add them up and then what do we do
we divided right we took the average
between them there you go
so how do you get the x coordinate of
the midpoint well you add up those two x
values divided by 2
what about the y coordinate how do you
get that in exactly the same way but for
Y's instead X's y 1 plus y 2 divided by
2 and that my friends is the midpoint
formula that's it it's simple in some
ways it's the easiest of all of them
because we get like halfway that's a
really easy visual thing to see where as
gradients a bit a bit funny and
distances up it's quite complicated
curve Pythagoras but midpoint
I think we've nailed it so well done